a professor at NYU has just suggested a
new course for students which is the
teaching of mating
Dynamics we used to call this the birds
and the bees you know you would teach it
to like 11 year olds but now because of
the stunted development and Perpetual
adolescence of American people uh now
you've got to teach this to 22 year olds
now you got to probably 25y olds this
guy's a business school professor and
and I think he's right I think he's
mostly right here's his argument we're
developing these digital analoges of
life that create low entry low risk
relationships and you think well that's
not necessarily a bad thing but it is
because it leads to depression life is
about the
victory of taking risks enduring
rejection and quite frankly pursuing
someone and developing the skills and
deciding to put on a clean shirt and
maybe shower more often and maybe hit
the gym every once in a while and maybe
text when you're not sure how this
person feels about you and figure out a
way to interact with someone around the
Nuance nuance and develop the skills
around human sexuality such that you can
develop a relationship and I think every
every teenager in in high school should
have a course as part of Health on
mating Dynamics where they teach
especially young men that approaching a
woman and expressing romantic interest
while making her feel safe is a skill
and there's nothing wrong with that and
at the end game a relationship a partner
a romantic uh partner is one of the keys
to a happy
life this guy
is almost totally right he this guy is
it's not just 50% right he's 70% right
the only thing I disagree with him on is
the phrase mating
Dynamics is that makes us sound like
animals makes us sound like gorillas
makes us sound like
horses I we got that and here we are we
have the NYU student approaching the
young girl at a coffee shop let's see
what kind of weird depraved stuff he
does that's really really embarrassing
to both of them yes that's what that's
what you would see today in a nature
documentary on young people's mating
Dynamics and people do need to learn it
but what we call that in a more human
sense is courtship what we call that in
a human sense is romance what we call
that in a human sense is being normal
and being a red-blooded man talking to a
lady it's not it's not just mating
Dynamics it's not just because we're not
just beasts we're human beings and so
there there's more to it but his broader
point is
right when he says having a good
romantic partner is a key to a happy
life well let let's take that up to the
human level again having a spouse is an
important aspect of a happy life not
everybody gets married marriage is not
for every single person some some people
have a consecrated single life some
people are called to religious life
priesthood to uh some kind of religious
order but for most people marriage is
what you're called to and marriage is
higher than just a romantic committed
relationship and I'm not being pedantic
here and I'm not splitting hairs the
reason that distinction is important is
because if we continue to
approach the relationship between the
Sexes as nothing more than animals
grunting trying to get what they want
then then we're going to maintain this
dysfunction that we're in we have to
recognize that we're human beings and
we're called to a higher CT of sort of
mating dynamic between men and women
both of whom are made in the image and
likeness of God right now go to
genucell.com everyone here at the office
loves the genus cell darkspot corrector
you might be asking what this product
even does well if you've got sunspots
dark spots discoloration or dry skin the
genus Cell Dark Spot Corrector will help
those blemishes disappear in front of of
your very eyes Kimberly from youngst
Ohio says my appearance has improved so
much since using genus cell I love all
my genus cell products and my skin looks
younger now it's your turn to feel like
Kimberly but hurry this sale is ending
very soon take advantage of genus cell's
most popular package which includes the
Beloved Dark Spot Corrector this package
also includes the genus cell classic
under eye treatment you will get all
these products for almost 70 70% off J
cell is so confident in their products
that you can try them for yourself
completely risk-free if you don't see
immediate results you will get your
money back it's very simple go to
gel.com
kwes start looking years even decades
younger tomorrow say hello to the best
skin you've ever had at jus.com
genucell.com
canes the reason that he thinks this
needs to be taught now though is clear
enough it's because of ubiquitous online
porn and because of the apparent Advent
of these AI sex chat Bots which is
something mercifully I don't know
anything about I didn't even believe
this was really a thing until I read a
news story on it I brought it up on the
show I think last
week and it's it's at once extremely sad
and pathetic and I have a deep well of
pity for anyone who is using these tools
but I get how it could be tempting I do
every all the other commentary on these
AI weird chat things is how pathetic it
is and these guys are just big losers
and they're incels sure maybe all that's
true but I get how it's tempting I get
how it's tempting these these chatbots
according to at least the Articles I've
read about them they they develop to
tailor their language specifically to
your desires to your tastes to
preferences that you might not even know
that you
have the the deck is really stacked
against you the deck is really stacked
against young men how are young men
supposed to acclimate and and become a
cultured in a normal way in a good
flourishing way in a world that Plies
them with ubiquitous porn that that
applies them with the me too movement BS
that says if you ever smile at a girl
and she doesn't like you she can accuse
you of rape that that that Plies you
with all of these weird chat robots and
and things to distract you and take your
attention away and that PES you with the
the lies of the hookup culture that when
you do actually meet a you can never you
can you can never pursue her in a normal
way you've just got to get completely
blackout drunk or do some drugs or
something and then have a hookup and
then hope she doesn't regret it because
then you'll be expelled from school and
possibly go to prison for
rape that that's a that's tough this is
where I have some sympathy for the red
pill guys because then by the way if you
do get married the legal deck is stacked
against you where uh you you have a
regime of no fault divorce where the
woman could take your money and your
kids at any given time and that's very
scary I think there are ways to greatly
mitigate that that risk this is where I
differ from the red pill guys which is
they they observe that divorce rates are
sometimes in the 40s not quite 50% but a
little under that and that might be true
but among Catholics it's at least 10
points lower than that among traditional
Catholics it's virtually nil I suspect
those numbers hold true for other
seriously minded religious communities
Orthodox Jews for instance I don't think
I don't think the heds are divorcing at
a at a 50% rate far from it of
course there are things that you can do
there are ways that you can live your
life that will mitigate these risks and
that will be more conducive to human
flourishing that's what this professor
is talking about and this guy is right
he's at a a top school NYU Stern School
of Business and he's absolutely right
what does it profit a man to learn how
to make a bunch of money or be a
Management Consultant or make widgets at
the widget Factory if he loses his soul
and loses the prospect of having a wife
and a family and a good life boy what a
great clip that was now stop hold on
stop stop stop stop stop ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael nlls YouTube
channel and we'll see you next time